did this leave you with the itch to act
and if so what particular acting muscle
are you looking forward to exploring in
your next film show you yeah for sure
yeah this is a really really interesting
experience because like I haven't seen
the Final Cut of this film and I'm gonna
watch that tonight and I think that's
like that's that's gonna like give me a
lot better like of a clue of like
whether like or not I want to keep doing
this can I just clarify no you're gonna
see the movie and yeah you better be
proud of yourself I think a lot of
people in the audience will yeah much
like the enthusiasm I might cry I
watched like the very first cut of it
like a Super Fresh off of filming and I
couldn't cry but I watched it with my
manager and he never cries but he cried
that night so it was awesome but I uh
you know
I but before I'm using my main passion
was like like cinematography and I was
doing like VFX and all that kind of
stuff so I was behind the camera a lot
but I had to act in it because I didn't
know anybody else to be in it
that was that was like my first and only
like uh experience with acting so
because it's like the first time where
I'm actually like in a fit like feature
film you know it was it was crazy it was
like fun but it was like so much it's a
new experience and you work so hard as
an actor that's one of the things that I
learned it's like acting as like really
just mentally just like you you're on it
for like you know however long you're
shooting for and you just focused on
that only and that is definitely
something that I would like to explore
but I also am like have I have no idea
what kind of like roles I want to play
uh you know I think after this is a good
time for me to like take acting classes
because not every shooting opportunity
I'm gonna be with a director who's like
okay with like giving me a month of
rehearsal and you know being that
comfortable on camera so that's
something that I'm gonna have to like
it's a skill that I'm gonna have to keep
sharpening and but I will say there are
like a few shows that I watch in there
where like I get so into that that shows
world that like I would do anything to
be part of that show
one of them is the boys I really like
the boys and uh I uh I I felt that way
when I watched Euphoria too because but
I think a part of it is also like me
feeling like I missed out on going to
high school because I could totally see
you in a show like Euphoria yeah dude I
second that I I last night at the party
I saw this one guy from Euphoria too
which is crazy but uh yes I I see myself
in certain shows and uh this one that
that came out recently is The Last of Us
I love that show and I played both of
the games played both of the games so uh
if you want me to play Jesse I'm down
you know
we manifest things we manifest things at
this table you speak it into existence